why didn't you ever have children
yourself did you ever watch him well yes
in fact my husband now were married 50
years a couple of years ago and we
thought at the start we would have
children we even had names for them and
all but it never did work out that way
and then you know how time goes by and
you think well I think it was not meant
for us to have kids and now you can
influence the lives of so many children
I hope so oh everybody's kids to be mine
now 50 years is amazing it's an amazing
time an amazing amount of time to be in
love with somebody and to share that
time with somebody what are you guys
doing a date night well we do whatever
we please you know he doesn't like to
get out in public that much but we we
have our little RV camper now somebody
told me that you actually enjoy going
through like a Taco Bell drive-thru
together is that true well yeah we go
through all the drive throughs together
in our little RV doesn't have to be Taco
Bell but we like that but we like all of
them ah we hear them all from her
honesty to her unforgettable hits
[Music]
dolly parton has carved a career that
spans five decades of today she adds her
impressive list of achievements with her
first ever children's album called I
believe in you
[Music]
why now and why it's [ __ ] Dublin I
have the Imagination Library where I
give children books from the time
they're born to learn start school and
all through the years have been writing
songs based on the books that we give
out
so I've accumulated all these songs and
then when the coat of many colours at
Christmas so many colours movies did so
well with the children it just hit me
like a lightbulb this is the year to do
a children's album we're excited about
it and all the money from it goes to the
imaginers library good not something
around the neighborhood 100 million
books so far we're excited we actually
we started this 28 years ago and in my
hometown my dad was my inspiration my
dad was never able to read write and so
I'd always wanted to do something for my
dad and so he got to live long enough to
see this come to fruition and so it
means a lot to me
who believed in you when you're going up
well my mother I was close to my aunt's
my grandma's and so there were a lot of
wonderful women in my life
speaking of inspirational women you know
your goddaughter Miley is refreshing to
a lot of people what was it like or what
has it been like watching her grow as an
artist it's not watching one of your own
children grows she's like one of my kids
I've known her since she was tiny little
baby and I'd always known she was so
talented so gifted and I knew what she
was going through when she was trying to
make her own way after Hannah Montana
and she you know she I've said she's
gonna always land on her feet no matter
how high she jumps and you know it's
like she and she has and she will and we
just wrote and recorded a song together
on her new album that's right rainbow
right so what was it like working with
her we get excited you know with each
other
it's our voices blend good and if this
does well and even if it doesn't we
really saw that we really shouldn't be
singing more together